>>> A LITTLE BOY LEFT WITHOUT
PARENTS AND HIS BROTHER NOW
AMONG THE HEARTBREAKING STORIES
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THE VICTIMS
KILLED IN HAD SATURDAY'S MASS
SHOOTING AT A TEXAS OUTLET MALL.
A 3-YEAR-OLD AND HIS PARENTS,
KOREAN AMERICANS, WERE GUNNED
COUNT.
A 6-YEAR-OLD SURVIVED.
THAT ACCORDING TO A GOFUNDME.
ALSO LOST, TWO SISTERS IN 4th
AND 2nd GRADE.
THEIR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL DESCRIBED THEM AS TWO
RAYS OF SUNSHINE.
THEIR MOTHER IS IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
A 20-YEAR-OLD MALL SECURITY
GUARD, 27-YEAR-OLD ENGINEER, AND
32-YEAR-OLD ALL DEAD.
ALL KILL E
ED BUT A HATEF.
WE'RE LEARNING ME MADE
DISTURBING SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
FIXATED ON MASS SHOOTINGS.
LET'S GO LIVE TO JOSH CAMPBELL
LIVE AT THE SCENE.
>> Reporter: A LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOURCE PREVIOUSLY TOLD ME THAT
INVESTIGATORS HAD UNCOVERED
THIS.
WE'RE SEEING THE IMAGES FROM
OURSELVES.
CNN HAS IDENTIFIED A SITE, A
RUSSIAN SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM
WHERE THIS SHOOTER HAD AN
ACCOUNT.
HIS ACCOUNT IS JUST REPLETE WITH
ALL KINDS OF VIOLENT MATERIAL
ABOUT NAZIS, WHITE SUPREMACY,
HIS OBSESSION OVER FIREARMS AND
PAST MASS SHOOTINGS AND LOOKING
TO THOSE AND DISCUSSING THOSE
TYPES OF ATTACKS.
HE OBVIOUSLY IS ACCUSED OF
COMING HERE THIS WEEKEND AND
KILLING EIGHT PEOPLE AT THIS
MALL IN ALAN, TEXAS.
HE'S DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS AN IN
CELL, IT'S ESSENTIALLY A MAN WHO
BLAMES WOMEN IN SOCIETY FOR HIS
LACK OF ROMANTIC SUCCESS.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING NEW DETAILS
AND I'LL SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
PHOTOS OF THE ACCOUNT A THAT
APPEARS HE CONDUCTED
RECOGNIZANCE.
YOU SEE A PHOTO FROM THE PARKING
LOT, RESEARCHING ON GOOGLE MAPS.
WHAT ARE THE BUSIEST TIMES OF
DAY AT THIS OUTLET MALL, TRULY
TROUBLING STUFF.
I'M LEARNING MUTT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FIREARMS THAT THE
SUSPECT HAD.
A SOURCE TELLS ME THAT
AUTHORITIES RECOVERED MULTIPLE
FIREARMS, INCLUDING THE AR-15.
I'M TOLD THAT ALL OF THOSE
FIREARMS WERE PUCHASED LEGALLY.
MOST OF THEM FROM PRIVATE
SELLERS.
THE REASON WHY THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND WE OFTEN HEAR
PEOPLE SAY LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT
POLITICS OR POLITICIZE THAT.
POLITICS DRIVES POLICY.
HERE IN THE STATE OF TEXAS, IF
YOU BUY A GUN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECK.
>> JOSH CAMPBELL, THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME INSIGHTS FROM THE
FORMER FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR
McCABE.
NUMBER ONE, THE MILITARY SAID
GOOD-BYE TO THIS GENTLEMAN
BECAUSE OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
HE'S BUYING GUNS HE'S POSTING ON
THESE RUSSIAN WEBSITES.
BUT SO THERE'S A LOT OF DOTS OUT
THERE.
TEXAS HAS NO RED FLAG LAW.
THERE'S NO BACKGROUND CHECK IF
YOU BUY FROM A PRIVATE SELLER.
WAS THERE ANY WAY TO CONNECT
THEM, OR IN THE WORLD HE WAS
LIVING IN, IS THIS WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> VERY HARD TO CONNECT THEM.
EVEN IF IF HE TRIED TO PURCHASE
A GUN THROUGH A FIREARMS DEALER,
UNLIKELY HIS PAST EMOTIONAL
TROUBLES WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
OBSTACLE.
SO THIS IS JUST A VERY, VERY
FAMILIAR STORY OF ANOTHER
ALIENAT
ALIENATED, ANGRY YOUNG MAN,
GRAVITATES TOWARDS THESE
COMMUNITIES OF THESE EXTREMIST
COMMUNITIES, EXTREIST
IDEOLOGIES AS A WAY OF SEEKING A
COMMUNITY, SEEKING THAT SORT OF
AFFIRMATION FOR HIS OWN ANGER
AND BELIEVES AND CAREFULLY
PLANNING OUT THIS MASSACRE AND
EXECUTING IT IN THE MOST LETHAL
WAY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DEFEND
COMPANIES BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF HATE ON THOSE SITES AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THESE
SITES HAVE COME UP AFTER
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
TALKING ABOUT THE GLORY OF MASS
KILLINGS.
WE DEFEND THE FIRST AMENDMENT
HERE TO THE END, OBVIOUSLY.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO BE DONE
BECAUSE THERE'S ANYTHING IN THE
LARCENY OR A LAW THAT COULD HELP
WALL THAT OFF?
>> NOT CURRENTLY.
THERE ISN'T REALLY A FIRST
AMENDMENT CONSISTENT WAY OF
EXCLUDEING PEOPLE FROM SEEING
THESE SITES.
ASK THEY ARE JUST AS YOU
DESCRIBED.
IT'S TRULY THE WILD WEST.
THERE'S NO CONTENT MODERATION.
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO POST, IT
ATTRACTS THAT EXTREMIST
COMMUNICATION AND COMMUNITY FOR
THAT REASON.
>> SO WE ARE AT 208 MASS
SHOOTINGS.
IT'S MAY.
208 MASS SHOOTINGS IN THE UNITED
STATES SO FAR IN 2023.
YOU WANT YOU TO LISTEN HERE.
HE'S THE SHERIFF IN FLORIDA WHO
SAYS IT'S TEXAS THIS WEENG.
FLORIDA BEFORE.
SWR
OMEWHERE ELSE NE.
THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT KEEP
HAPPENING.
>> IT'S THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IT'S THE INDOCTRINATION OF THE
FAR EXTREME CHAT ROOMS.
IT'S MENTAL ILLNESS, THE ACCESS
TO FIREARMS.
IT'S A GRIEVOUS AGAINST PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
THIS WAS A WELL-PLANNED ATTACK,
AS WAS NASHVILLE, AS WAS THE
SUPERMARKET IN BUFFALO.
THEY SCOUT THE AREA.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A HIGH BODY
COUNT.
THEY KNOW THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THEY ARE LOOKING TO ERADICATE
FROM THE WORLD.
>> EVERY SHERIFF HAS BECOME AN
EXPERT THIS THIS JUST BECAUSE IT
KEEPS HAPPENING.
THE SHERIFF SAYS HIS DEPARTMENT
HAS USED THE RED FLAG LAW MORE
THAN 200 TIMES SINCE IT PASSED.
TEXAS DOES NOT HAVE ONE.
DOES THAT MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
>> IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE AT THE
MARGINS.
BUT LET'S GO RIGHT AT THE
PROBLEM.
THERE'S ONLY ONE THING THAT
MAKES US DIFFERENT THAN EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY THAT EXPERIENCES
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS, THEY
HAVE ANGRY PEOPLE, PEOPLE WITH
GRIEVANCES, THE DIFFERENCE HERE
IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT
CATEGORY, YOU CAN ALSO BECOME
INCREDIBLY, HEAVILY ARMED WITH
THE MOST LETHAL MILITARY WEAPONS
AVAILABLE INSTANTLY.
THAT IS WHY WE EXPERIENCE GUN